they were trying to make an example of
him and that really seems to subvert the
idea of justice what we hope for
hi I'm Zach why smaller with reason TV
i'm here at the Electronic Frontier
Foundation headquarters in San Francisco
with Parker Higgins internet activist
and friend of the late programmer and
activist Aaron Schwartz Parker thank you
very much for talking to us Aaron
Schwartz who sadly committed suicide
last week contributed a lot to the
culture and substance of the internet
could you just describe what some of his
what you see is some of his bigger
contributions sure uh well when he was
just 14 he was a co-author on a
specification called RSS which is used
on almost every major web site around
the internet and it just developed from
there he was he played an integral role
in the launch of Creative Commons
licenses of free copyright licenses that
are used on Wikipedia and on hundreds of
millions of different works around the
web and later you know he was he was
working even though he was only 26 when
last week when he when he died he'd been
working for a decade and a half and he
had done a lot of really important
activism he founded a group called
demand progress which was really one of
the groups of the center of protesting
the the SOPA proposal and getting that
stopped Schwartz ran into some serious
legal trouble when he downloaded of
about four million articles from the
academic journal site JSTOR from the MIT
on the MIT Network the federal
government charged him he was facing up
to 35 years in prison a million dollars
what do you think about how the
prosecution against him was handled I
think that there's pretty clear evidence
that it was over broad and it was taking
advantage of a law that is written too
vague and with to harsher penalties and
it looks as if we've seen this with
other other especially computer
developers like they were trying to make
an example of him Schwartz's father
has actually said that he thinks that
the federal government is in part
responsible for his son's suicide do you
think that's a fair statement it's hard
to get into the head of someone who has
made the decision to kill himself and we
can't know even if that's not the case
they were responsible for for causing
him a lot of undue stress and really
threatening to ruin his life and and
that's as big a problem last week as it
is this week the idea that an agent of
the federal government would be able to
pick out a person and and you know
threatened to ruin their life is not the
kind of thing that we hope for in a
justice system you said earlier that you
think that they were making an example
of him why would they choose him as an
example and what what's the message that
you think was trying to be communicated
there before this incident with JSTOR he
had downloaded many many files from a
system called pacer which holds court
records and he had made those files
which are in the public domain and
generated with with public money he had
made them available free on another site
and the FBI investigated that and
couldn't find anything to charge him
with so there are some people who think
that these JSTOR charges being
especially harsh were the result of a
vendetta there the US attorney who was
in charge of prosecuting him actually
said I'm in a reader statement real
quick stealing is stealing whether you
use a computer command or a crowbar and
whether you take documents data or
dollars it is equally harmful to the
victim whether you sell what you have
stolen or give it away does she have a
point there I mean why doesn't stealing
now this is that's absolutely it's it's
just an example of how wrongheaded this
prosecution was the purported victim
JSTOR first off they never lost anything
you know if stealing is stealing and
it's
the same with with data or dollars than
you'd expect when you steal dollars from
somebody they don't have those dollars
JSTOR never lost anything children and
it's also worth mentioning with JSTOR
actually dropped their civil chart uh
they didn't want to pursue a civil case
against him so it really was the federal
government pushing this right yes and
and so it's really that's a that's a
false comparison and it's that kind of
thing that that really makes these
computer laws so out of whack that that
they reflect a reality that just doesn't
doesn't exist what he did did seem like
it was some sort of political act in a
way what was driving him when he did
that and and what what what did what did
he stand for he was a long time
committed activist in the name of free
access to information and I I believe
that Aaron would agree with the
sentiment that your access to the
collective knowledge shouldn't be
contingent upon you having you attending
a university that has a JSTOR
subscription or whether you can afford
to buy these articles one by one that in
fact that access to knowledge should be
available for everybody regardless of
their status where do you fall on that
question do you think that all every
document all knowledge should just be
out there for free for public
consumption so I mean if you're asking
me personally I think that our current
copyright laws are are not based on a
sane system of providing incentives that
you could imagine a government granted
monopoly it through copyright may be
worthwhile for incentivising certain
kinds of creation but but the idea that
it should be life plus seven years and
that and that the rights holders should
be able to go after really clear fair
pieces and and found them seems like
it's it's not an ideal system what
should we learn from all this what big
changes would you like to see moving
forward well i mean first and foremost
we'd like to see reform to the Computer
Fraud and Abuse Act and we've already
seen rep Zoe Lofgren in California has
proposed some changes in some areas they
don't go far enough but but these
changes are long overdue and extremely
important we also because one of erin's
causes that he believed in so deeply was
open access we'd like to see more work
done in the area of universities and
academics making their works available
on it on a free access basis and that's
there's already been a decade of work in
that arena but hopefully we can take
some of the energy that's that's really
been that's been expressed in the last
few days and channel that towards
improving the open access world Parker
Higgins thank you very much for joining
us Thank You Zach for reason TV I'm Zach
why similar
you